en deuxième partie de soirée honnêtement
je l'aimais bien deuxième partie de
soirée aux ennemis dont mr lucas et
quand je passe à côté d'un deuxième
partie de soirée elle a sa place quand
tu dis que c'est bien c'est pas vrai
qu'ils sont là il sent extrêmement
déjanté au contraire pour isabelle sont
déjantés d ac/dc des ouf ils ont fouillé
dans le rang ils ont foutu un dhow
j'étais le dawa sur le plateau la wii
wii no c'est une double catastrophe et
économique effectivement et éditoriale
on comprend rien ouais c'est pas ton
argent
[Applaudissements]
effectivement je te connaissent
effectivement à titre personnel je n'en
ai rien à [ __ ] et ça comme tu l'a très
justement dit mais je ne te laisse pas
quand tu prends la parole il me semble
[Applaudissements]
et des missiles bonne quand toutes les
équipes au site écolo mais ce soir ils
sont payés vous kiffez le lot si vous
écrivez dans les chaumes et un petit
billet et je trouve en plus que c'est
une émission quelque peu excluante je ne
doute pas que ceux qui seront sur le
plateau et l'éclat et les candidats
s'amusent de ouf mais je trouve que ça
prend pas on n'a pas le temps de
regarder ses six aînés